so this is something I wanted to talk
about this week because we did the
abortion video with Samantha B and we
don't have a whole ton of time so you
see these you've seen these bumper
stickers that are aimed at our
Republicans pro-life once you're born
they don't care they're just Pro birth
right now all these up here how to tell
if a Republican is pro-life or just anti
woman ask them to raise taxes to feed
hungry babies
these are bumper stickers this is bumper
sticker knowledge and you'll see this
plastered on Facebook as memes again
because of the problem all over Twitter
every sjw and their mother and here's
the problem with that and this is what I
think is one of the fundamental
differences between the left and people
like us they immediately attribute
motive yes for example you've heard me
say this many times about Bernie Sanders
I think the guy is delusional I think
he's wrong but I think he genuinely
wants to help right there people like
Hillary Clinton or just conniving
horrible awful terrible wenches yes but
I do think there are plenty of liberals
particularly young liberals young
leftists who want to help and they're
misguided how many times have you heard
us say that liberals right away
attribute Republicans just hate kids
Republicans just hate black people just
hate women Republicans just hate queers
Republicans just hate chicks with dicks
that's the we're gonna have to get that
on the second half I didn't even realize
that that just came out that's not it
cause it rhymes rhymes fronnies are the
non offensive term let me explain this
somewhat rationally Republicans people
like me conservatives we're pro-life
because we are over all pro Liberty
that's what it comes down to we don't
oppose socialized healthcare because we
want poor people to die we oppose
socialized healthcare because we want
more people to live that's why I oppose
socialized healthcare I've looked at the
health projections I've looked at the
likeliness of dying from a terminal
illness and it is higher virtually
everywhere in the United States if you
have a terminal illness your best chance
of living is the United States being a
United States citizen we don't oppose
Republicans don't oppose the current
public school union run regime because
we want kids to be stupid we oppose it
because we want children to be provided
with the choice we want parents to be
provided with a choice that's why we've
pushed for school choice programs school
vouchers charter schools all of which
they're god-king john oliver crap on and
say let's funnel more money into the
current public school system we don't
welfare state because we want people to
be poor we opposed it because we want
people to thrive and we see how the
welfare state has destroyed lives let's
talk about the black American family
after Lyndon Johnson it decimated black
American families because it was an
incentive to remain in a welfare state
and by the way the single greatest
indicator you could possibly have of
economic health of personal health
wellness longevity kids going to serve
you stay out of prison his thing that a
prison his marriage is our mommy and
daddy in the house are they married that
that it's not even close school money
none of it and that's what Republicans
that's what conservatives have always
supported you may not like it you may
not like the idea of a nuclear family
but we support that because we want kids
to thrive minimum wages they don't
create wealth they eliminate jobs that's
why we oppose them health care mandates
don't make insurance more affordable
they skyrocket premiums as we've seen
this week socialized health care doesn't
take people healthier they put you
before death panels who determine
whether you get to get end-of-life
treatment live or die that's another
thing isn't the left if they say well
partial birth abortion isn't a thing of
course it was a thing that's why it was
banned Hillary Clinton fought against
getting it banned now that's not the
medical terminology is called dilation
and extraction we give it a term that
people can understand just like dolphin
is not the actual scientific term for a
dolphin don't ask me what it is I know
with whales it's a Monsieur Marius we
know that oh yeah don't oppose Hillary
as Clinton as we know that I don't know
dolphins so we give it a term
partial-birth abortion because it's a
way that someone can understand it's a
way that someone can process it say
anything with death panels member
there's no such thing as a death panel
no one thinks that there's a Death Star
and Emperor Palpatine is gonna come out
and say little die what we're talking
about is the government at this point
having to ration care do you know how I
know there are death panels because my
aunt was put in front of one with lung
cancer that was Stage four by the time
the panel could even determine her
course of treatment in Canada in Canada
this is why in Canada 2005 we've talked
about this show we versus Quebec Supreme
Court case they said it's a violation of
Human Rights to ban privatized health
care because people are dying and they
have the right to pay for health care so
this idea that Republicans aren't Pro
birth because we just
support furry crap at the expense of the
taxpayer all the time it's not because
we don't care about people it's because
we care more about people and we have a
fundamental understanding of how the
world works don't allow yourself to be
tricked by this or even use that term
that term compassionate conservative was
used to try and fight back for a while
because people felt guilty listen there
is nothing more compassionate than
capitalism than free enterprise and
conservatism the people who are greedy
little bastards want to get their hands
on everything and absolutely destroy it
like the spoiled toddlers that they are
are the left is to put that bumper
sticker on their Prius which by the way
is worse for the environment with two
giant non recyclable batteries you want
to be better for the environment go buy
a crappy beat down car it's not even
close they don't have to make a new one
stop driving your Prius they also handle
like crap it's a white guilt mobile and
I hate you Dana lash next hey Jeff
laughing this video is taken from the
full weekly podcast louder with Crowder
subscribe by clicking it Jarrod's
laughing because he's acting just got
shot the loss of blood is making him
delirious who shot him
guilty